(fun happy music)
- [Narrator] Many modern-day fisherman
have a big fish story.
But in Ancient Japan, the
tiniest fish was the big catch.
(speaking in foreign language)
(moves into dreamy music)
The art of tanago tsuri is
named after the tanago fish-
one of the smallest fish in the world.
(speaking in foreign language)
But these special fishing
rods are hard to come by.
That is where Toryo and Shuhei come in.
(speaking in foreign language)
The two brothers have been making
Edo Wazao fishing rods
for the last 15 years
in the hopes of carrying on the tradition.
(speaking in foreign language)
(moves into funky electronic dance music)
Each rod can take up to
half a year to finish.
(speaking in foreign language)
(rustling)
(click)
(scraping)
(speaking in foreign language)
(pleasant orchestral music)
(sonic beep)